it seems sherita's well and truly sold
on a new idea
okay I just don't think a word the tapas
I'm gonna come up with my own word I'm
gonna make up but I guess I can't call
it slap us cuz that sounds too rude the
mummer's on a crusade alright and we're
launching tomorrow we have a big party
ten pounds each three courses jambalaya
barbecue chicken going by tomorrow night
Charita wants the whole of west sussex
to know about mama Sherry's and its
brand new bid week eating concept soul
in a bowl when you're hungry and you
need of a serious food attack just come
to mama cherries the soul food shack
we've got so little bone three yummy
courses served on a platter
fried chicken jambalaya and more we're
talking soul food tapas the price is so
right so come to the shack two night
things you have that huge plug for
nothing
thank you
on a normal Wednesday night Charita
would be lucky to get eight customers
but whilst we've been out bookings for
the seasons launched have gone through
the roof it's all coming together except
for one small hitch
there's no Brian there's no ad there's
no Gavin no one's here Brian's stuck
with the [ __ ] babysitter somewhere
God knows where and you know what if
they were gonna get this place right
then they're gonna have to really
understand discipline because this is a
joke big day no one in the [ __ ]
kitchen